an ecologist surveys the age of about a
hundred trees in a local forest he uses
a box and whisker plot to map his data
shown below what is the range of tree
ages that he surveyed what is the median
age of a tree in the forest so first of
all let's just let's make sure we
understand what this box and whiskers
plot is even about this is really a way
of seeing the spread of all of the
different data points which are the age
of the trees and to also give other
information like what is the median and
where does most of where do most of the
ages of the tree sit so this whisker
part so you can see this black part is a
whisker this is the box and then this is
another whisker right over here the
whiskers tell us essentially the spread
of all of the data so it says the lowest
data point in this sample is an
eight-year-old tree i'm assuming that
this this axis down here is in years and
it says that the highest the oldest tree
right over here is 50 years so if we
want the range and when we think of
range in a statistics point of view
we're thinking of the highest data point
minus the lowest data point so it's
going to be 50
minus 8. so we have a range of 42. so
that's what the whiskers tell us it
tells us that everything falls between 8
and 50 years including 8 years and 50
years now what the box does the box
starts at well let me explain it to you
this way the mid this line right over
here this is the median
this right over here is the median and
so half of the ages are going to be less
than this median we see right over here
the median is 21. so this box and
whiskers plot tells us that half of the
ages of the trees are less than 21 and
half are older than 21. and then these
endpoints right over here these are the
medians for each of those sections so
this is the median for all of the trees
that are less than the real median or
less than the main median so this is the
middle of all of the ages of trees that
are less than 21 this is the middle age
for all of the trees that are greater
than 21 or older than 21. and so these
essentially are splitting we're actually
splitting all of the data into four
groups this we would call the first
quartile so i'll call it q1 for our
first quartile i'll maybe i'll do one q
this is the first quartile a roughly a
fourth of the trees because the way you
calculate it sometimes a tree ends up in
one point or another about a fourth of
the trees end up here a fourth of the
trees are between 14 and 21 a fourth are
between 21 and it looks like 33 and then
a fourth are in this quartile so we call
this the first quartile
the second quartile the third quartile
and the fourth quartile
so to answer the question we already did
the range there's a 42 year spread
between the oldest and the youngest tree
and the median age of a tree in the
forest is at 21. so even though you
might have trees that are as old as 50
the median of the force is actually
closer to the lower end of our entire
our entire spectrum of all of the ages
so the the if you view median as your
central tendency measurement it's only
at 21 years and you can even see it it's
closer to the left of the box and closer
to the left the the end of the left
whisker than the end of the right
whisker